allez on passe aux sports et la soirée
d'hier a été fructueuse pour les
basketteurs de l'utbm pour leur avant
dernier match de la saison les joueurs
de pierre tavano n'ont fait qu'une
bouchée de leurs adversaires toulousains
score final 80 à 67 l'accession en pro b
est désormais à portée de main en main
delville à la fin du match c'est une
joie contenue pour les basketteurs de
l'utbm pour se qualifier dès hier il
fallait passer 17 points à toulouse
score final 81 67 14 points d'écart
la montée se jouera donc à challans
samedi pour la dernière journée
mais c'est maintenant l'utbm qui a seul
son destin en main pour laisser toulouse
derrière au classement
en face mentionne aurait aimé finir à
domicile qu'on sait que ça va être un
déplacement compliqué maintenant voilà
comme je dis on est vraiment dans le
vestiaire est vraiment très heureuse
avec toi c'est pas une déception on le
prend pas comme ça au contraire ça donne
encore plus envie d'aller est allé finir
le turban
c'est que tout en maîtrise son sujet
d'entrée de jeu et prend à la gorge
toulouse en cassant son jeu de passes
48,25 à la mi temps et c'est sans
discussion mais comme à chaque match il
y à un troisième quart temps et comme à
chaque fois tourné pas dedans toulouse
grignote grignote la rencontre pas d'
intenses attendues et de tendu et
électrique dans le dernier quart tous
regardent de la distance à plus de dix
points
l'équipe a vraiment du caractère c'est à
dire qu'elle a de l'envié elle l'a
montré sur la première mi temps parce
qu'on fait vraiment une première mi
temps de rêve forcément toulouse qui est
une équipe très forte est revenu mais on
n'a pas paniqué on les a pas laissés
revenir près de nous on a même pu jouer
le panier un virage sur la fin mais bon
c'est pas grave on n'a pas le panier
avérage maintenant on va le gagner à
chalon en gagnant toulouse l'utbm
s'offrent le droit à la montée en pro b
samedi en vendée
si les tourangeaux y met la même
détermination la même envie et la même
rigueur rien ne peut leur arriver